qu'est ce que la science vous allez
répondre que c'est ce qui explique le
monde qui nous entoure les atomes
l'énergie les ordinateurs les
communications le fonctionnement du
corps humain la vie des étoiles etc
tout ça est vrai mais la science est
aussi beaucoup plus que ça la science
est aussi ouvrir notre imagination nous
faire voir ou de l'innocence nous forcer
à réfléchir autrement nous forcer à voir
la réalité autrement
aujourd'hui je vais vous donner deux
exemples de sang deux exemples qui
viennent de la théorie de la relativité
d'albert einstein le premier exemple est
quelque chose qui est parfaitement bien
vérifiés en laboratoire
de toutes les façons qu'ont pu
s'imaginer portant ça a l'air tellement
incroyable faire l'air tellement est
possible que souvent on refuse le croire
pourtant c'est la stricte vérité
c'est l'idée que le temps est relatif
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que l'écoulement du temps peut être
modifié et là je parle du temps
fondamental le temps physique
fondamentale qui contrôle le
fonctionnement des horloges le
vieillissement de nos corps la
croissance des plantes
et c est bien ce temps peut ralentir ce
temps peut être contrôlée de deux façons
par de grandes vitesses ou de grande
force de gravité mais aujourd'hui je
parlais seulement deux vitesses voici
une petite histoire
supposons vous partez en fusée à très
grande vitesse justement c'est à dire
une vitesse très proche de celle de la
lumière donc parti en fusée pendant un
an et à cause de votre grande vitesse
votre temps s'écoule au ralenti dans la
fusée pendant que le temps sur la terre
lui s'écoule normalement et pendant
votre année de voyage
il pourrait par exemple s'écouler 50 ans
sur la terre et donc quand vous allez
revenir sur la terre et sortir doit
refuser
vous allez découvrir que vous êtes rendu
50 ans dans le futur de la terre que les
gens que vous connaissiez à vos départs
sont rendus cinquante ans plus vieux
et si vous voyagez encore plus vite
votre temps dans la fusée va être encore
plus ralenti et vous allez revenir
encore plus loin dans le futur de la
terre peut-être dans 100 ans ou même
dans 2000 ans c'est exactement cette
histoire qui se passait dans le fameux
film culte l'appel des singes ou des
astronautes par terre à très grande
vitesse ont fusé pour revenir dans le
futur lointain de la terre et découvrir
que c'était maintenant les singes qui
avaient pris le contrôle de la planète
ce n'est pas entièrement de la science
fiction
on fait bien sûr aujourd'hui on n'a pas
encore la technologie pour envoyer des
fusées à des vitesses proches de celle
de la lumière
mais un jour on va être capable c'est ça
qui va se passer mais entre temps ont
réussi à vérifier ça exactement ça dans
les accélérateurs de particules
voici le plus gros accélérateur de la
planète
c'est au cern le centre européen de
recherche nucléaire
c'est un très long tunnel de 27 km
souterrain dans lequel on accélère des
particules justement des vitesses ultra
proche de celle de la lumière
donc imaginez ce tunnel qui dure comme
ça pendant 27 km l'accélérateur en tant
que tel c'est le tuyau en métal dans
lequel circulent les particules est
entourée de champs électriques et
magnétiques pour contrôler et justement
les particules et ce tunnel est
tellement longue que les techniciens se
promène en scooter électrique ou
meilleur pour la santé en vélo et donc
les particules sont des protons vont
tellement vite dans cet accélérateur que
leur temps s'écoule sept mille fois plus
lentement que le nôtre d'accord mais
comment être certain que leur temps
s'écoule vraiment au ralenti eh bien on
a fait de notre expérience avec d'autres
particules qu'on appelle des murs sont
des particules instable c'est à dire des
particules qui vivent très peu temps
on les crée elles vivent très peu de
temps puis disparaissent
eh bien ces particules qu'on les fait
voyager à très grande vitesse dans
l'accélérateur
on les fait vivre trente fois plus
longtemps que normalement
donc elles vieillissent vraiment 30 fois
plus lentement que normalement est donc
clairement leur temps s'écoule 30 fois
plus lentement que normalement
en fait toutes les expériences faites à
ce jour ont parfaitement bien vérifier
que l'écoulement du temps peut bel et
bien ralentir exactement tel que prédit
par les équations d'albert einstein et
donc si le temps est remarqué que ça
implique aussi qu'on peut contrôler
l'écoulement du temps parce que plus je
voyage vite plus je ralentis montant est
maintenant je vais vous donner trois
exemples avec des chiffres pour bien
pour mieux comprendre en fait cette idée
donc je vais faire trois voyages qui
vont toujours durer une année
mais à trois vitesses différentes non
premièrement je pars à 90 % de la
vitesse de la lumière
je fais un voyage qui dure un an pour
moi et je vais revenir sur une terre qui
est heureux vieilli de 21.6 grosse
différence maintenant je repars faire un
deuxième voyage encore plus vite à 99 9%
de lecture de la lumière
cette fois toujours durant une année
pour moi je vais revenir sur une terre
plus vieille de 20 ans et si je vais
encore plus vite à 99.99 9 9 9 % de
l'état de la lumière
eh bien je vais revenir deux mille ans
dans le futur de la terre
ça peut sembler incroyable notre cerveau
à la misère à comprendre comment c'est
possible
pourtant c'est comme ça qu fonction de
la nature et voilà justement un exemple
de sciences qui nous force à réfléchir
autrement qui nous force à remettre en
question notre vision de la réalité et
qui nous dit en quelque sorte que la
nature est beaucoup plus subtil que ce
que nos sens perçoivent un oui très
important cette idée de faire cette
possibilité en fait de faire des sous
dans le futur de la terre ou si loin
qu'on le veut
n'implique pas que le futur existe déjà
je répète c'est simplement l'idée de
ralentir l'écoulement de son temps en
voyageant à grande vitesse pendant que
le temps s'écoule normalement sur la
terre et que le futur se construit
normalement sur la terre mais maintenant
posons la question inverse
est ce qu'on pourrait faire des sauts
dans le passé et ça ce serait mon
deuxième exemple qui vient aussi de la
théorie de la relativité
mais cette fois c'est une idée
spéculative c'est à dire une idée qui
n'est pas vérifié encore une idée qui
pourrait être possible et pour faire des
sous dans le passé au préalable il faut
que le passé existe encore en quelque
part il faut vraiment que le passé
existe encore pour que je puisse y
retourner et ça c'est l'idée du temps
comme une quatrième dimension vous pour
commencer pour simplifier l'idée du
temps comme une dimension qu'est ce que
ça veut dire exactement ça veut dire que
le temps se comporte un peu comme
l'espace imaginez-vous en voiture sur
une route vous avancez vous croiser une
maison une fois que la maison ait croisé
et qu'on ne la voit plus la maison a pas
disparu et les simplement rendu derrière
nous dans l'espace est bien la même
chose est vraie pour le temps je vis
j'évolue et donc lorsque j'évolue
j'évolue le long d'une ligne temporelle
et lorsque je vis un événement et qu'il
est terminé
l'événement ne disparaît pas il se
retrouve derrière moi sur ma route du
temps je vais vous montrer un petit
vidéo dans quelques instants pour mieux
comprendre cette idée mais juste avant
je dois parler des dimensions combien
dimension connaissez-vous normalement
trois largeurs profondeur et hauteur
ici le temps est une dimension ça veut
dire que c'est une quatrième dimension
qui se rajoutent ou trois autres pour
faire qu'à dimension en tout
mais nos sens n'arrive pas à visualiser
cas dimension donc pour simplifier la
présentation je vais réduire le nombre
de dimensions en jeu je vais commencer
avec un monde plat à deux dimensions
comme la surface d'une table avec un
disque est un carré et dans quelques
instants
je vais rajouter le temps comme une
troisième dimension et là on va pouvoir
le visualiser mais avant tout en
regardant le mouvement donc le disque
tourne en rond le carré regardez bien
tourner sur lui-même et maintenant je
vais rajouter le temps comme une
troisième dimension vers le haut les
remarques et bien ce qui va se passer
sur le plan rectangulaire de couleur
blanche
je parle vidéo et en se déplaçant vers
le haut ils leurs produits sur sa
surface
le mouvement du rond et du carré
le mouvement du disque qui tourne en
rond et regardez bien le mouvement du
carré qui tourne sur lui même
voici différents moments maintenant un
peu plus tard encore plus tard et voici
maintenant l'idée crucial quand je suis
rendu ici dans le temps ce qui s'est
passé avant ici existe encore ne pas
disparu donc ceci verticalement c'est la
ligne du temps en vers le haut je suis
rendu ici dans le temps et les positions
précédentes du carré et dureront et du
carré existe toujours en arrière dans la
dimension temporelle
je le répète encore parce que c'est
l'idée crucial je suis rendu ici dans le
temps mais le passé ici ce qui a été
vécu avant existe toujours
donc voilà la conséquence absolument
fabuleuse de l'idée
temps comme une dimension le dernier
exemple une danseuse du dimensions pour
simplifier et maintenant son mouvement
dans l'espace temps donc voilà l'idée du
temps comme une dimension je répète ici
pour simplifier on a réduit le nombre de
dimensions en jeu je suis parti de monde
plat de dimension des rondes et carrées
je rajoutais le temps comme une
troisième dimension
dans la réalité notre espace à trois
dimensions et le temps est une quatrième
dimension très difficile visualisez même
pour des physiciens
il faut vraiment pousser notre capacité
d'imagination a ses limites
pour commencer à imaginer la situation
mais l'idée est la même le temps est une
dimension d'accord pour tout ça
supposons que le temps est une dimension
supposons que le passé existe encore
maintenant est ce qu'on peut y retourner
dans ce passé comme par exemple dans le
film back de futures voilà une question
absolument fascinante qui est une
question fondamentale de recherche
aujourd'hui en physique mais aujourd'hui
personne ne connaît encore la réponse
mais peut-être qu'un jour ce sera vous
qui allez la trouver merci